quoi on paraît que vous avez une
surprise pour pour moi encore si je ne
sais pas jean prises pour vous oui non
ah oui ah bah si c'est oui parce qu'il
était meilleur quand il est avec toi et
pas du tout à l'heure j'ai tenté de
venir chez vous oui et je n'ai pas
réussi puisque c'est chez moi je vais
retrouver des dvd beaucoup d'animaux
d'ailleurs ça sent pas bon du tout chez
moi et par est d'accord oui il ya donc
une autre porte parce que je pense avoir
vraiment un
et là je ne crois pas du tout à ce que
je vais dire je pense avoir trouvé
vraiment votre domicile voile alors là
c'est là ils m'ont dit il m'a dit les
mozilla une surprise pour un chroniqueur
a alors on m'aura pas informés c'est ça
c'est moi non non a lancé je suis moi
non mais c'est pas du montage là c'est
la panne ou la sentra d'eau là c'est ma
porte sur ce que c'est matthieu
delormeau qui habite de ses parts
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
matt frattin johnny
[Applaudissements]
attention marbre merde et la salle des
mots ses choix ouais allez allez allez
dans la salle rock dans la salle de bain
non allez dans la salle de bal que j'ai
laissé pas dans l'assurance partout
n'ont jamais dire la salle de bains
passe partout et maintenant le trailer
il est pas dans la salle sur balles et
merci dd volée ratée après dix années le
bal à la ola
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans la chambre de mathieu j'étais bon
coup sûr non sans émotion s'associe à
dire trouver une robe sombre décor du
succès mois
[Musique]
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils ont prouvé à tous les tiroirs c'est
vrai quoi avoir un québécois il ya des
déchets que les soirées sont bonnes pour
que oui